y la exclusión de cuba nicaragua y
venezuela de la novena cumbre de las
américas ha puesto en jaque el futuro de
la reunión sumándose a su homólogo
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador el
presidente de bolivia rizar se amenazó
con no asistir si no se invita a estas
naciones
consecuente con los principios y valores
del estado plurinacional de bolivia
reafirmó que una cumbre de las américas
que excluye a países americanos no será
una cumbre de las américas plenas y de
persistir la exclusión de pueblos
hermanos no participaré de la misma
anb lo había dicho previamente que
enviaría al canciller marcelo ebrard en
su representación si eeuu no atiende su
petición de incluir a todos los países a
la cumbre y reiteró que era momento de
unión en alusión a la guerra en ucrania
el presidente argentino alberto
fernández también pidió a washington que
revierta su decisión y aunque el
anfitrión aún no ha hecho oficiales las
invitaciones naciones como paraguay
colombia y ecuador ya confirmaron su
asistencia somos respetuosos de la
decisión del dueño de casa de invitar a
quienes de ellos consideren prudente
y mantiene con eeuu de una relación muy
positiva y sobre todo compartimos
ideales de libertad de democracia y
vamos a una cumbre de las américas que
tendrá varios retos sobre todo en el
análisis económico de los impactos que
tiene la región por la coyuntura de la
guerra a rusia y ucrania
sobre los retos de transición ecológica
y sobre los retos de migración además de
la migración la pandemia y la lucha
contra la polarización son algunos de
los temas que se esperan los jefes de
estado y de gobierno de las naciones del
continente traten en su encuentro que
tendrá lugar del 6 al 10 de junio en los
ángeles y que regrese a la unión
americana por primera vez desde su
creación en 1994 bajo la administración
del entonces presidente bill clinton